مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون عزام احييكم
والتغطيه لا زالت مستمره للاوضاع في
السودان يوم عاشر من المواجهات المسلحه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وفي تصعيد
جديد اتهم الجيش السوداني تهما قوات الدعم
السريع باستخدام المدنيين دروعا بشريه في
الاثناء بدات الازمات تتوالى السودانيون
يعانون لخدمات اساسيه لسلام تحت اصوات
الرصاص فيما تتواصل عمليه نزوح واسعه هربا
من الاشتباكات هذا وتستمر عمليه الاجلاء
التي تنفذها الدول الغربيه والعربيه
لدبلوماسيه
ورعاياها وهذه مشاهدينا صور مباشره لاعمده
الدخان من قلب العاصمه الخرطوم وقد تم
الابلاغ عن سماع ذوي انفجارات وكما نشاهد
تصاعد لاعمده الدخان
وهذا او هذه الرقعه تحديدا هي من مطار
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
وفي التفاصيل مشاهدينا اعلن الجيش
السوداني استقرار الموقف العمليات الجيش
الشرفي بيانه الى توسيع نطاق تامين منطقه
الخرطوم لتجنب الحاق اضرار بالمناطق
السكنيه فيما جدد دعوته لعناصر الدعم
السريع بالاستسلام بيان الجيش اتهمه قوات
الدعم السريع باستخدام المدنيين كدروع
بشريه البيان اكد ان الاتصالات ما زالت
مستمره مع الدول الاجنبيه الراغبه في
اجلاء الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
وقد نشر الجيش مقطعا مصورا لانضمام احد
ضباط الدعم السريع وذلك استجابه لدعوات
سابقه طلبت عناصر الدعم السريع بالاستسلام
دعونا نتابع انا الرايت حسين هدايا
تابع لقوات الدعم السريع والان انضميت
اختي الان انضميت للقوات المسلحه
وباغرار
الاغرار القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ومهاي 125 فرد وخمسه وعشرين عربيه
وبناشد اخواني في الدعم في الدعم السرير
لسه ينضمون للقوات المسلحه لحقنا للدماء
ولحقنا للدماء وانا بناشد اخواني كلهم في
الدعم السريع والجيش انضموا كل من دمه في
يحضر القوات المسلحه ونحن متكيفين ذات
القرار السيد الغايب
لارجاع قوات القوات الحرس الحدود للقوات
المسلحه
وفي المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع من
اسمتهم بعناصر النظام السابق بتنفيذ
عمليات تخريب واسعه من بينها نهبوا منازل
المواطنين ومقر الشركات والمصانع اعتبرت
قوات الدعم السريعه ان هناك خطه وصفتها
بالمشبوهه بتنفيذ عمليات سلب ونهب والصاق
التهمه بعناصرها مشيره الى انها تعمل على
تامين مصادر الخدمات الضروريه مؤكده انها
ليست مسؤوله عن انقطاعها قالت قوات الدعم
السريعه انها تعمل على توفير الخدمات
الضروريه للمواطنين وتامين مصادر هذه
الخدمات الى جانب تامين عمليات اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه
الطرق وتسهيل عبور المواطنين الى المناطق
الامنه
[موسيقى]
ربنا يستر
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
[موسيقى]
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
المزيد معنا من بورت سودان مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي اهلا بك نزار كيف تسير عمليه
الاجلاء
يعني الان بعد ان اعلنت السلطات في
السودان باغلاق المجال الجوي لكافه الحدود
في السودان توجهت الانظار ثوب الشرق
السودان تحديدا الى هذه النقطه التي تتحدث
منها قناه العربيه في مدينه بورسودان على
ساحل البحر الاحمر منذ الحادي والعشرين من
هذا الشهر بدات عمليات الوصول من قبل
الدبلوماسيين ورعايه الدول العربيه
والافريقيه والاجنبيه الى مدينه بورسودان
في مسعن لتكمله اجراءات الخروج من السودان
بعد ان قالت مصادر في الجيش السوداني بان
القائد العام للجيش وجه كافه الجهات
المعنيه هنا في شرق السودان وفي عدد من
المعابر بتهيئه المناخ والاجواء لعبور امن
لكل من يرغب من الرعايه والدبلوماسي
لمغادره السودان من خلف مباشره تتابعون
هذا هو الساحل البحر الاحمر وهذا هو ميناء
بورت سودان الذي تتوجه اليه الانظار انظار
العالم والذي يشهد الى جانب مطار بورسودان
الدولي عمليات الاجلاء
لمئات الرعايه والدبلوماسيين الراغبين في
الخروج من السودان
علمنا ايضا بعد ان وصلنا الى شرق السودان
بان اللجنه العليا المكلفه لعمليه اجلاء
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين ومن يرغب في الخروج
من السودان بان هنالك لينه
مكونه من لجنتين فرعيتين اللجنه الاولى
تتعلق بتامين الاجلاء عبر مطار بورسودان
وعبر القاعده الجويه هنا في شرق السودان
وهي برئاسه اللواء طيار وهنالك ايضا لجنه
مختصه بالاجلاء عبر البحر عبر هذا الميناء
الذي تشاهدونه الان وعبر القطع البحريه
والبواخر التي تصل تباعا الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر والى هذا الميناء هاتان اللجنتان
تعملان بتنسيق كامل مع الامن البحري مع
هيئه الموانئ البحريه مع الشرطه في اداره
الجوازات مع الجيش مع الاستخبارات من اجل
تامين امن ومستقر لخروج كافه الرعايه
الذين وصلوا بالمئات الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر الان نحن نتحدث تجري عمليه اخر
الاجراءات المتعلقه
بتهيئه الاوراق الثبوتيه والجوازات لرعايه
دوله الهند في السودان وابناء الجاليه نحو
الف من الهنود الان في طريقهم لمغادره
مساء هذا اليوم هنالك نحو ست باصات سفريه
الان ايضا في طريقها الى مدينه
الجاليه الاندونيسيه
والبريطانيون الان ايضا في طريقهم الى
بورسودان لاستكمال عمليه
الاجلاء ايضا في هذه اللحظات التي نتحدث
فيها وصلت قبل قليل عادت من افواج البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الدوليه العامله في
السودان للامم المتحده يبدو انها ارتات
بان الخيار الافضل للخروج من السودان يكمن
في ولايه البحر البحر الاحمر ويكمن في
الميناء الجوي الذي تستعد من خلف مباشره
عدد من القطع البحريه لمباشره مهامها
والنقل عدد من الجاليات من هذه المنطقه
سواء الى جده او الى عدد من الموانئ
الدوليه في الجانب الاخر من البحر ن الدعم
السريع كانت تقول بانها تعمل على تامين
عمليات الاجلاء بصورات عامه ماذا تعني
بذلك ومن يرافق هؤلاء منذ خروجهم من
الخرطوم حتى وصولهم الى
لم استمع الى السؤال جيدا ولكن فيما يتعلق
بالوضعيه الامنيه
لمغادره كل من خرج من الخرطوم اذا سمحت
الصوره ساتوجه بالصوره مباشره
لطريقه الاخر لعكس وصول ايضا عدد من
الباصات السفريه او اذا كان الامر عسيرا
على الكاميرا فعدد من الباصات السفريه
وصلت الان الى مدينه بورسودان كل الذين
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه الى البحر الاحمر
سالناهما عن طريقه الوصول عن العقبات التي
جابهاتهم اشاروا فيما اشاروا من خلال
حديثهم بان الامور كان السالكه بعض
العقبات في الشارع ولكنهم اشادوا بالطريقه
التي تم استقبالهم بها في شرق السودان
والتنسيق الذي قام به الجيش في سبيل
وصولهم الى ميناء بورسودان الى المطار
قالوا ايضا بان الضيافه كانت ممتازه
تم تقديم الضيافه تم تسهيل الاجراءات
المتعلقه بالاوراق الثبوتيه وتوفيق اوضاع
من لم ياخذ اوراقه الثبوتيه من العاصمه
الخرطوم وصل بطرق عسيره
وشائكه الى ولايه البحر الاحمر نعم نزار
كان بالامكان تحريك الكاميرا لنشاهد اكثر
التحركات على الارض فيما يتعلق
بمن وصل حتى الان الى بورتسودان وحتى
تتحرك الكاميرا ونشاهد هذه الصور للجهه
الاخرى ان امكن
نزار حيث ذكرت نحن في نحن في مقابل نعم
نحن في مقابل الساحل البحر الصور التي
تحدثت عنها هي لي باصات سفريه باصات النقل
كانت قد مرت خلال المباشر نحو ست الى سبعه
باصات سفريه
يرافقها رتل من السيارات يتبع للامم
المتحده ولمنظمه الغذاء العالميه وصلوا
قبل قليل الى
مدينه بورسودان لتوفيق ايضا اوضاعهم
وللخروج عبر البحر وعبر الطيران خلال
الساعات المقبله
انها متوقفه وبالتالي طلبت تحريك الكاميرا
كي نشاهد هذه الجموع على كل نزار عندما
سالتك فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع الامنيه لهؤلاء
ووصولهم خروجهم من داخل الخرطوم ومنذ نقطه
الانطلاق من يرافقهم وكيف تتم عمليه
التنسيق ان لم يكن هناك من تنسيق حقيقي ما
بين الطرفين المتصارعين كيف تتم عمليه
التنسيق
لكي يخرجوا خروجا امنا ام انه تم تحديد
ممرات امنه محدده لهؤلاء من قبل الطرفين
فيما يتعلق بالذين وصلوا الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر
ذكروا لنا ونحن استطلعنا عدد منهم
واستمعنا الى افادتهم وايضا تحدثنا الى
قيادات عسكريه هنا في شرق السودان اكدوا
بان الجيش هو ينسق تنسيقا كاملا مع
البعثات الدبلوماسيه في سبيل اطمئنان
الدوله السودانيه واطمئنان المبعوثين
والرعايه على
الطريق الامنه التي سيخرج بها من يريد ان
يخرج من السودان الجيش قال بانه ينسق
تنسيقا محكما مع مختلف الوحدات العسكريه
سواء كان في الخرطوم او في الطريقه الرابط
بين الخرطوم ومدين الشندي شمالا ومدينه
عبر شمالا ومنها شرقا الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر هنالك ايضا تنسيق محكم كما علمنا
من بعض المصادر العسكريه بين الجيش وبين
جهاز المخابرات وبين الاستخبارات العسكريه
وبين هيئه الموانئ البحريه وبين امن الامن
البحري والامن الجوي كل هذه المنظومات
تعمل بتنسيق وبتناغم من اجل خلق ارضيه
مستقره لخروج الالاف والمئات من الرعايه
ومن الدبلوماسيين ومن المواطنين للدول
الاجنبيه الذين يودون الخروج من هذه
النافذه البحريه الوحيده للسودان اللجنه
التي تم تشكيلها والتي تنقسم الى فرعين
لجنه المطار ولجنه البحر هي لجنه ايضا
تعمل بتنسيق مشترك الى جانب وجود هيئه
الجوازات السودانيه التي تعمل على مدار
الساعه لمده 24 ساعه في اليوم تعمل بتنسيق
دائم وعلمنا ايضا بان الجهود الان مستمره
خلال الساعتين المقبلتين لتفويج الجاليه
الهنديه نحو 400 الى 500 هندي سيغادرون
عبر قطعه بحريه الى ميناء جده ومن ميناء
جده ستقلهم الخطوط الجويه الهنديه الى عدد
من الدول ومنها
عبر القطارات الى عدد من المدن والمقاطعات
الهنديه نؤكد بان هذه العمليه حسب الجيش
تتم وفقه تنسيق ووفق تناغم تام بين مختلف
الوحدات العسكريه والامنيه هنا في شرق
السودان ذكرت انك استطعت ان تتحدث مع
البعض
من هؤلاء والسؤال يتعلق بالحاله النفسيه
مشاهداتك لهم وهل يقدم لهم اي دعم النفسي
الان قبل انطلاقهم الى حيث سيذهبون
هذه النقطه جيده يجب ان نسلط عليها الضوء
مساله الدعم النفسي والدعم الايجابي الذي
وجده مئات الرعايه ومئات من ينظمون تحت
السلك الدبلوماسي الذين وصلوا الى الشرق
السودان مدينه بورسودان كما تشاهدين هي
مدينه ساحليه مدينه سياحيه اكتظت خلال
الساعات الماضيه بمئات من رعايه الدول ومن
المبعوثين ومن المنتمين للبعثات
الدبلوماسيه والدوليه
طرحنا هذا السؤال على القائمين على امر
رعايه الدبلوماسيين والاجانب كيف سيتم
تقديم الدعم قالوا بان هنالك لجان لتقديم
الغذاء لتقديم الدعم هنالك ايضا لجان طبيه
للطوارئ اذا ما استدعت الضروره ذلك ابناء
الجاليات الذين يسكنون ويقطنون هنا في شرق
السودان لسنوات عديده ايضا نسقوا واتصلوا
على ابناء الجاليات التي وصلت الى شرق
السودان راينا قبل قليل في مقر الجاليه
الهنديه هنا في بورسودان طريقه تقديم
الغذاء والسند الشعبي الذي يوجد من قبل
ابناء الجاليه لكل من وصل الى بورسودان
ايضا الجاليات الاردنيه عندما وصلت يوم
الامس الجيش السوداني خان قد قدم الدعم
والسند لهم حتى وصلوا الى مطار بورسودان
وبعدها مباشره غادروا عبر الطائره الى
المطار مطار الاخر ايضا الجاليه السودانيه
عندما الجاليه السعوديه نتحدث عندما وصلت
الى ميناء بورسودان والى هذه المدينه
الجيش كان قدم الدعم والسند وهيا كل
الظروف في سبيل ان تنجح عمليه وصول
السعوديين وعدد من الجاليات الى الجانب
الاخر من هذا البحر وبالفعل نجحت هذه
التجربه الجيش يؤكد بان هذه الامر العمليه
هي عمليه معقده عمليه تحتاج الى تنسيق
لكنه يجتهد في سبيل انجاح عمليه اجلال كل
الرعايه الذين وصلوا الى شرق السودان سواء
عبر البحر او عبر المطار نعم على كل
النزال شكرا على المعلومات التي قدمتها
نعود اليك في نشراتنا اللاحقه ربما من
موقع اخر حيث يتواجد فيه هؤلاء الرعايه
الاجانب الذين هم بصدد الخروج من السودان
من بورتسودان كان معنى نزار بقداوي مراسل
العربيه
اظهر مقطع فيديو تم تداولها عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي حجم الدمار الذي تعرضت
له منطقه الكلاكله كلاكله قبه جنوب
الخرطوم بسبب الصراع الحاصل بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه
وطبعا بهذا الاطار في هذه المنطقه تحديدا
نحاول ونتابع العواجل الان التي تتحدث عن
مقتل سبعه مدنيين في تلك المنطقه منطقه
الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم جراء ما ذكرناه من
قصف لمروحيه للجيش على كل مع استمرار
المواجهات يدفع المدنيون الثمن كعاده اي
صراع خاصه ان كان هذا الصراع مسلحا نقابه
اطباء السودان افادت بان مناطق عده في
العاصمه الخرطوم تعرضت لقصف بالاسلحه
الثقيله النقابه اعلنت عن مقتل عدد من
المدنيين في عدد من المناطق تحدثنا عن سبع
مدنيين في الكلاكله مضيفه ان المستشفيات
باتت مكتظه بالاصابات الخطيره ونشدت نقابه
اطباء السودان الكوادر الطبيه لتقديم
المساعده وتقديم يد العون للكوادر العامله
بالمستشفيات
قبل ذلك اعلنت نقابه الاطباء ارتفاع عدد
الوفيات منذ بدايه الاشتباكات الى 273 من
المدنيين النقاب سجلت حوالي 1580 حاله
اصابه منذ بدايه الاشتباكات مؤكده ان
العدد مرشح للزياده مع صعوبه في الحصر
الدقيق بسبب صعوبه التنقل بين المستشفيات
اشارت النقابه الى ان 69% من المستشفيات
باتت متوقفه عن الخدمه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا لازمنا نتابع هذه الصور التي
تنقل لنا الدخان المتصاعد من مطار الخرطوم
حيث ذوي انفجارات نسمعها بين الفينه
والاخرى
هذا ومع استمرار هذه الاشتباكات تستمر
خدمه الانترنت في الانقطاع بالسودان بشكل
شبه كامل وذلك وفق ما افاد موقع نيت بلوكس
المعني بمراقبه الانترنت اظهرت بيانات
الموقع انهيار شبه كامل للاتصال بالانترنت
لتصل نسبه الاتصال الى 2% مقارنه
بالمستشفى بالمستويات الطبيعيه
اسبوع ثاني اذا من المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان لصوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص ولا
مؤشر ينذر بحل قريب المواجهه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بدات باطلاق نار كثيف حول
مباني المدينه الرياضيه في منطقه سوبا
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم القتال انتقل
سريعا ايضا الى حي المطار المتاخم لمقر
القياده العامه للجيش وحيث يوجد ايضا بيت
الضيافه الذي يقيم فيه طرفاه الحرب
البرهان ودقله وكبار القاده العسكريين وسط
الخرطوم وبينما تداولت وسائل الاعلام عن
الدعم السريع سيطرته على مطار مروي
والقاعده الجويه اضافه الى الاعلان عن
احتجاز عدد من الضباط كانوا في القاعده تم
تداول ايضا معلومات عن استيلاء قوات الدعم
السريعه على القصر الجمهوري في قلب
الخرطوم اضافه الى اجزاء واسعه من مقر
القياده العامه للجيش نيران الحريق امتدت
بعدها الى خارج الخرطوم لتصل عددا من
المدن نتحدث عن النياله الفاشر والجنيه في
ولايات دارفور ومدينه الابيض في ولايه
شمال كردفان القتال ايضا تركز حول مقرات
الدعم السريع في شارع عبيد ختم وفي مدينه
بحري وام درمان ليس معروف على وجه الدقه
من يسيطر على ماذا فكل طرف يزعم بسط
سيطرته على موقع استراتيجي قبل اي بادر
الاخر سريعا باعلان الشيء نفسه
الصور ايضا وثقت تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
محيط الصفاره الكويتيه بالخرطوم اثرى
الاشتباكات الدائره
[موسيقى]
اصبحت مدينه الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه
هانئه مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح
الاسواق ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
[تصفيق]
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
على كل المزيد معنا في الاستوديو مديره
مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم لينا يعقوب اهلا
بك لينا بدايه ما المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا وما طبيعه القصف الذي يستهدف منطقه
الكلاكله طبيعه هذه المنطقه اهلا بك يا
ميسون هي منطقه سكنيه مدنيه عاديه ولكن
طالما ان هناك تصوير للمواطنين عبر
هواتفهم لطائرات فنحن نعلم ان الجيش
السوداني هو الذي يمتلك الطائرات الدعم
السريع ليس لديه طائرات صحيح ان هناك
تشابه في بعض الاسلحه المستخدمه في هذه
الحرب ولكن ايضا هناك اسلحه خاصه للجيش
السوداني يبدو انها توثيق لاول مره بان
تحلق هذه الطائرات وتقصف مواقع سكنيه
ويبدو بحسب الانباء المتواتره انه قد شكوا
بوجود بعض افراد او عناصر للدعم السريع في
هذه المنطقه ولكن طبعا هذا الامر بخطوره
بمكان لماذا لان الان هو استهداف مباشر
يتاثر منه المدنيين في وقت سابق قال تسقط
يعني بعض
القذائف وتتضرر منها منازل ولكن ان يكون
الاستهداف في وسط هذه الاحياء هذا امر
جديد وخطير طبعا وطبعا ذكرنا قبل قليل
الاعداد حتى الان ما سجل من سقوط للمدنيين
سبعه مدنيين حتى الان في تلك المنطقه
تحديدا وهنا السؤال هل لدينا معلومات عن
حجم هذا القصف وان كان لازال مستمر ام انه
ضربه سريعه كانت للجيش السوداني كيف هو
الوضع لدينا معلومات او لا المعلومات من
نقابه الاطباء ومن الجهات الطبيه والصحيه
كانت تناشد الاطباء بالحضور الى احد
المستشفيات في تلك المنطقه نسبه
لقله الكادر الطبي طبعا هناك ايضا قله في
المستلزمات الطبيه الموجوده هناك نحو 50
مصاب هذه هي المعلومات الاوليه هناك ايضا
عدد من القتلى البعض يتحدث الان عن سبعه
قتلى قد يزيد طبعا هذا العدد الامور بعد
قليل السؤال خاصه انه ذكرتي ان هناك
توثيق للطيران طيران الجيش واستهدافه لتلك
المنطقه هل لدينا معلومات ان كان هناك
ايضا انتشار للدعم السريع على الارض لانه
الجيش يتهم الدعم السريع على انه يستخدم
المدنيين ايضا دروع بشريه صحيح هذا هو ما
يقوله الجيش السوداني باعتبار ان الدعم
السريع بحسب شهود عيان وبحسب مواطنين في
كثير من المناطق السكنيه في الخرطوم وبحري
وام درمان شاهدوا دخول مدرعات تتبع لدعم
السريع قريبه من الاحياء السكنيه طبعا
الشوارع كثيره هناك شوارع فرعيه وشوارع
رئيسيه الدعم السريع يتواجد في شوارع
رئيسيه في بعض المناطق ولكنها قريبه من
المساكن القريبه جدا من المشاكل المدنيه
فبالتالي حاله الكروه الفار التي تكون بين
الجنود من كلا الجانبين في الاقتتال
الدائر في هذه المناطق تضطر في بعض
الاحيان الدعم السريعي للدخول الى المناطق
السكنيه وهو الامر الذي كان يؤخر الجيش في
الدخول ولكن بالمشاهده التي رايناها اليوم
لم نتاكد انها طائره سوداني ولكن نعلم ان
الدعم السريع ليس لديه طائرات ولذلك حينما
حاول الدخول في بدء هذه الاشتباكات الى
قاعده مروي كان الهدف الاساسي السيطره على
الطيران السوداني عند السيطره الكامله هي
للجيش السوداني ولكن هذه نقطه تعتبر خطيره
جدا فيما يتعلق بخرق قواعد الاشتباك وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بمباشره
بالمدنيين هل بدانا ننطلق بحسب المراقبين
وما تتابعينه الى ما هو ابعد من مجرد
اشتباكات ما بين الطرفين نعم ميسون لان
الوضع معقد وضبابي لا اعلم ان كان المشاهد
العربي يفهم ذلك ولكن حينما الجيش
السوداني يتحدث عن السيطره فهو يسيطر داخل
القياده العامه لكن خارج القياده العامه
ينتشر
الدعم السريع فهنا لا نستطيع ان نتحدث عن
سيطره للجيش السوداني كذلك ما يقوله الدعم
السريع حينما يصور بعض المقر التي دخل
وبعض مخازن الاسلحه وكذلك في القصر
الجمهوري هذا لا يعني انه يسيطر لان الجيش
السوداني ايضا يحيط بالمكان يعني ما في
خارطه يمكن وضعها والقول بانه هذه الجهه
تسيطر على تلك المناطق من غيرها ليس لدينا
امكانيه لمعرفه من هو الاقوى على الارض
الان بالضبط وهذه هي الاجابه المهمه ليس
لدينا امكانيه نحن كصحفيين ان اعتمدنا على
البيانات فالبيانات تتحدث بان كل طرف سيطر
على على هذا المكان ليس مسموحا للصحفيين
وحتى ما قاله نائب او قائد قوات الدعم
السريع نحن ما زلنا نستخدم في بعض الاحيان
لفظ نائب رئيس مجلس السياده لا اعلم مجلس
السياده يعني بشكله السابق سيكون موجود
ولكن قائد الدعم السريع كان يتحدث اين هم
الصحفيين الصحفيين او حتى المواطنين
العاديين لا يسمح لهم بالمرور او بالعبور
حتى في اوقات الهدنه وهذا هو الامر المهم
حينما نتحدث عنه هدنه فيعني ان يتحرك
المواطن بحريه من ام درمان البحري او من
بحري الى الخرطوم لكن هذه الجسور مسيطر
عليها بالتالي هناك صعوبه للحركه هناك
صعوبه في الدخول الى وسط الخرطوم لمعرفه
من يسيطر الان على وسط الخرطوم خاصه
المناطق المحيطه بالمطار وكذلك القصر محيط
القياده العامه هذا الانتشار العسكري
يختلط في بعض الاحيان على كثير من الناس
وعلى كثير من المواطنين
فالسيطره تظهر في الاعلام لكن يمكن التاكد
منها بعد ان يستطيع المواطلون الدخول
وحتى لو استطاع التحرك بحسب ما افهم
وذكرنا قبل قليل انه في مشكله بالانترنت
وبالتالي حتى قضيه التواصل مع الخارج ليست
بالسهله بالنسبه للمواطن السوداني الاتصال
الداخلي هل هو سهل او لا
كان ايضا صعب لان هناك انقطاع للشبكه
سوداني هناك ثلاثه شبكات هي التي تعمل في
السودان زين سوداني وام تي ان حينما تتضرر
الشبكه يلجا المواطنون طبعا الى شبكه اخرى
ونحن نعلم ان اي مواطن يستخدم
بطاقه الهاتف
لشركه من هذه الشركات لكن تاثرت كل هذه
الشركات في وقت مبكر من صباح هذا اليوم
وقبل قليل عادت بدات تعود تدريجيا خدمه
الانترنت بدات تعود خدمه الاتصالات لكن
هذا مؤشر ايضا سيء بان بامكانها ان تسوء
مره اخرى هذا التذبذب ليس فيه استقرار
سواء كافي الاتصالات او في الانترنت
للشركات الثلاث فيعني هذا يصعب طبعا
الحركه يصعب الحصول على المعلومه يصعب
التواصل بين السودانيين انفسهم وطبعا في
مشكله جديده شاهدنا قبل قليل صور للمطار
والدخان يتصاعد منه مطار الخرطوم هل لدينا
معلومات وهذه الصور طبعا نشاهدها على
الشاشه مقسمه الى اربعه ولا زالت صوره
مطار الخرطوم وان كان الدخان اقل من
السابق ولكنه لازال يتصاعد من هناك هل من
معلومات حول ما يحدث داخل المطار حول
المطار او لا هناك ضرر تحدث عنه بعض
المختصين في المطار الاصابات الاولى التي
لحقت بالمطار بحسب ما قالوا لم تكن قويه
او انها اصلاحات قد تستغرق عشره ايام وهو
الامر الذي لم يكن يشعر به السودانيون
لانهم راوا دمار في كثير من المواقع في
مطار الخرطوم البديل هو يكون هناك مطار
ولائي على استعداد
لاستقبال الرحلات الخارجيه وايضا هذا
المطر تلجا اليه رحلات كانت داخليه تتبع
لشركات سودانيه ثم تطور الامر لاحقا بان
تكون هناك بعض الشركات العالميه يعني تحضر
الى الى مطار بورسودان او الى بعض مطارات
دارفور الان هذا المطار يشير بصوره واضحه
الى ان عمليه الاجلاء ستكون مستمره عبر
البر اي عبر البحر اما الجده او عبر البر
عبر القدر الطائرات الامريكيه استطاعت
اجلاء مواطنيها هي طائرات عسكريه
بمعنى مؤهل على الاقل للطائرات كي تجتوا
عليه ولا لا ليس للطائرات العاديه لا يمكن
للطائرات العاديه بان ان تقلع منه او ان
تاتي اليه ولكن طبعا الطائرات العسكريه
والمروحيات العسكريه بامكانها ان تهبط في
اي مكان وهي لا تحتاج لامكانيات كبيره هذا
بطبيعه نوع الطائ
فالاجلاء الان يتم فقط سؤال اخير فيما
يتعلق بالاجلاء وكوننا تحدثنا عن
الامريكان نتحدث عن الالاف من الامريكيين
الذين الذين لا زالوا حتى الان متواجدين
داخل
السودان والخرطوم تحديدا هؤلاء الالاف
نتحدث عن سودانيين او بالاحرى امريكيين من
اصول سودانيه وارادوا البقاء ام ماذا ام
انه في العمليات ستستمر اكثر من ذلك نعم
بطبيعه الحال ليس كل من سمح له بالسفر قرر
السفر هناك كثير من المواطنين السودانيين
الذين يحملون يحملون جوازات سفر امريكيه
قرروا البقاء وربما يقيمون الوضع خلال
الايام المقبله بعد انتهاء مثلا هذه الحرب
او هذه الاشتباكات اما قرروا البقاء او
قرر ان تجليهم الولايات المتحده الى مديره
مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
لتواجدك معنا
قال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بان الكتله
الاوروبيه لن تسمح بانفجار الوضع في
السودان اضاف على هامش اجتماعي لوزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي ان عمليه اجلاء
موظفي الاتحاد قد نجحت
لقد كانت عمليه معقده لكنها ناجحه موظف
الاتحاد الاوروبي 21 شخصا موجودون بالفعل
في اوروبا والعديد من مواطني الاتحاد
الاوروبي خارج السودان بالفعل لا استطيع
ان اعطيك الرقم الملموسه لكن تقريبا اكثر
من الف شخص اود ان اشكر فرنسا على
مساهمتها علينا ان نواصل الضغط من اجل
تسويه سياسيه لا يمكننا ان نتحمل ان ينهار
السودان لانه سيرسل موجات صدمه في جميع
انحاء افريقيا
اذا تصريحات للعربيه نقلها مستشار حمدي
يقول فيها ان قوات الدعم السريع ستقبل
المناسبه من حكومه مدنيه وقبل ذلك كان قد
قال بان الدعم السريع لم تكن تريد ان تكون
بديل للجيش ولكن تريد اصلاح ونوافيكم
بالمزيد من التصريحات حاله ورودها نعود
الى تصريحات بوريل حيث قال ردا على سؤال
للعربيه ان المجتمع الدولي يضغط على
المكونين العسكريين في السودان يقوم ايضا
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب للوصول
الى تسويه سياسيه نتابعه
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على الطرفين ويقوم
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه لقد كنت اتحدث مع جميع
الجيران وجميع الاصدقاء حتى مع وجود
الجنرلين اللذين يقودان القوات رساله
المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب واسكات
المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث عن الحل
السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذه الحرب
وهذا ما نق وم به من خلال اخراج مواطنينا
لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك تراه انت
تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج مواطنون
ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
وفي اخر تطورات اجلاء الدول لرعاياها من
السودان وصلت اول طائره للقوات الجويه
الالمانيه الى برلين على متنها اكثر من
100 شخص تم اجلاؤه من السودان لذلك يصل
عدد الذين تم نقلهم من قبل الجيش الالماني
الى
313 شخصا حتى الان بحسب مصدر عسكري
الطائره وهي من طراز ايرباص 321 نقلت
هؤلاء الاشخاص من قاعده الازرق الاردنيه
التي يستخدمها الجيش الالماني كمركز
لعمليه الاجلاء الى برلين
ومشاهدينا ايضا العواجل وتكمله للتصريحات
تصريحات مستشار رحمتي للعربيه قال بانه
الدعم السريع ستحققه الاهداف المرجوه سواء
بالعمل العسكري او من خلال التفاوض نكمل
ايضا الوضع على الحدود بين مصر والسودان
دعونا نشاهد هذه الصور لعبور عدد من
شاحنات الاجلاء الى الاراضي المصريه وتشهد
الحدود المصريه السودانيه استنفار امني
وفقا لمراسل العربيه حيث وصلت دفعه جديده
من الحافلات لانهاء الاجراءات لدخول
الاراضي المصريه مراسل العربيه افاد بانه
من المنتظر وصول عدد من حافلات الاجلاء
خلال الساعات القادمه نتابع معا هذه الصور
ومشاهدينا في هذا السياق اعلنت سويسرا
اغلاق سفرتها في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم واجلاء موظفيها وعائلاتهم بسبب
الوضع الامني جراء المواجهات المستمره بين
الجيش والدعم السريع الوزاره اضافت انها
تمكنت من ذلك بفضل التعاون مع شركائها
خاصه فرنسا دون ذكر عدد الاشخاص الذين تم
اجلائهم
من جانبها وفيما تتسرع عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان اعلنت الخارجيه الصينيه انها
ارسلت قوه مهمات للسودان اجلت مجموعه من
الموظفين والمواطنين بامان الى احدى دول
الجوار المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
ذكرت ان بكين تتابع التطورات في السودان
عن كثب وتؤيد جهود التهدئه ووقف اطلاق
النار
اما فرنسا فاعلنت انها تواصل عمليات اجلاء
رعاياها والدبلوماسيين من السودان باريس
كررت دعوتها لوضع حد للقتال والعوده الى
المحادثات السياسيه بين طرفي الصراع مؤكده
انها لا تزال على اتصال وثيق بشركائها حول
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان
المدى الزمني للنزاع الدائر حاليا في
السودان غير واضح لكن اجلاء الدول
للدبلوماسيه
ورعاياها يؤشر لخطورته وطول امده حيث
تتواصل عمليات وجهود اجلاء البعتات
الدبلوماسيه العربيه والاجنبيه والرعايه
العرب والاجانب من السودان مع استمرار
المواجهات بين الطرفين
فمسارعه الدول الغربيه بمقدمتها الولايات
المتحده لاجلاء الدبلوماسييها واغلاق
السفاره مؤشر واقرار ضمني بان الحرب
الدائره قد لا تتوقف قريبا بحسب مراقبين
قرار الدول بني وفق مراقبين على استبعاد
تسويه عبر المفاوضات او حسم احد الطرفين
المعركه لمصلحته سريعا كما ان الخطوه
الامريكيه بارسال فريق استجابه للكوارث
الى المنطقه لتنسيق الاستجابه الانسانيه
للمحتاجين داخل وخارج السودان يعني غياب
اي مساء جديه او خطه ملموسه لوقف في
السودان ليبقى السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا هو
استمرار المعارك حينها كل طرف من اطراف
النزاع سيبحثوا عن داعمين له للصمود في
المعركه لاطول فتره ممكنه وبالتالي تعميق
الازمه علما بان عده قد فشلت وفر الالاف
من السودانيين بحثا عن الامان ان كان الى
تشاد المجاوره الفقيره ففي الخرطوم حاليا
لا ماء لا كهرباء والوصول الامن للطعام
غير مكفول
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من لندن الدكتوره رؤى عربي
صحفيه واعلاميه سودانيه اهلا بك دكتور
الرؤى اسمحي لي ان ابدا باخر التصريحات
التي نقلها مستشار حميدتي عبر العربيه قال
فيها بانهم سيصلون الى ما يريدون ان كان
بالحل العسكري او التفاوض طرح التفاوض
الان هل هو شيء جديد هل نحن نتحدث عن تغير
في اللهجه ام ماذا
مساء الخير نحب ابدا بانه الوضع في
السودان كارثي وماساوي بطريقه كبيره
بدعو لاهلنا في السودان بالرحمه والمغفره
لشهداء
وبدعوا انه الناس تحاول تساعد السودانيين
بقدر الامكان في هذه الظروف الصعبه
بالنسبه للتصريحات فهي تصريحات غير منطقيه
اذا كانت المفاوضات او الحديث بطريقه
سياسيه وبطريقه التفاوض ممكن ما كان لجؤوا
للحرب وللعنف هي مجرد تصريحات ف انا
بعتبرها المرحله وصلت انه الان يتم قصف
المدنيين الخاسر الوحيد هو المواطن
السوداني في وقت الهدنه كان بيتم القصف من
الطرفين
وتصريحاتهم الطرفين تتناقض مع الواقع
الحاصل في وقت الهدنه اليوم الثلاثاء
القبه تم تدمير اكثر من سته او سبعه بيوت
صحيح
حتى الان هذا حسب ما اعلن رسميا لا نعرف
ان كان العدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
صحيح في بحري سوق المركزي دمرت بالك
الفضاء التي حصلت العديد من الحوادث بتاعه
النهب المسلحه اللي قاموا بها
الدعم السريع او الجندويل بناء في
البيانات اللي بيطلعوها في صفحاتهم بانهم
يدافعون على المواطنين سوق الذهب ايضا
تعرض للنهب او تعرض للسرقه انا ما بعتبر
انه تصريحات الدعم السريع ومستشاري حميد
هي تصريحات واقعيه وحقيقيه لان الواقع من
المواطنين عكس الصوره اللي بتحصل
ابقي معي ساعود اليك ولكن دعينا نلقي
الضوء على عمليات الاجلاء التي قامت بها
الدول العربيه والاجنبيه لبعثاتها ورعايه
مختلفه الدول من السودان طبعا مع استمرار
المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
طبعا عمليات الاجلاء تمت عبر عده طرق
وبتنسيق مع طرفي النزاع لضمان سلامه
المواطنين والدبلوماسيين الراغبين في
مغادره السودان اعود اليك بعد ان نتابع
الوصول بمواطنيهم الى بر الامان كان هدف
الدول التي يوجد لها رعايه في السودان
لاخراجهم عبر عمليات اجلاء عاجله عده
مسارات تمت لعمليات الاجلاء منها عبر
قاعده ولد سيدنا الجوي في ام درمان ونقلهم
الى بورتسودان ومنها جوا الى دولهم خط اخر
للاجلاء كان ايضا عبر بورسودان لكن بحرا
عبر سفن حربيه تنقلهم الى مدينه جده على
الضفه الاخرى من البحر الاحمر قبل نقل
المواطنين الى بلدانهم من مسارات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب من السودان كان توقف
طائرات الاجلاء في الاردن كمحطه وقوف
مؤقته قبل الطيران الى السودان ونقل من
يرغب في مغادره البلاد واخر المسارات هو
عبر جيبوت المجاوره التي توقفت فيها
طائرات عسكريه من عده دول بغرض نقل
الرعايه من السودان ومن هذه المعسكرات
قاعده
التي تم عبرها نقل بعثه واشنطن في الخرطوم
اضافه لعشرات المواطنين من دول اخرى
وهذا عوده الى ضيفه الدكتوره رؤى للحديث
عن التطورات ولكن دعيني اشير الى ما ذكروا
مستشار حماتي للعربيه هدنه جديده خلال
ساعات طبعا كنا ايضا على العربيه بالامس
نتحدث ان الدعم السريع قد طرح فكره ان
استعداد لتمديد الهدنه ونحن نعود لنتحدث
عن هدنه جديده الى اي حتى تعتقدين انه
يمكن لهذه الهدنه بعد هذه التصريحات يمكن
لها ان تكون ملزمه للطرفين اكثر من
سابقاتها دكتوره من خلال التجربه الهدنه
عندما قامت الهدنه سابقا كان يتم اختراقها
سواء من قبل الجيش او الدعم السريع وبعد
ذلك بينشروا بيانات انه كل طرف يتهم الطرف
الاخر انه تعدى على فتره الهدنه القصف ما
وقف في السودان خلال الايام السابقه كلها
في مناطق مختلفه
في ذلك عن بدايه الاشت
باكات اخاف عن اليوم الاول والثاني لكن ما
زالت هنالك كل مره منطقه جديده يتم الهجوم
عليها فكره المفقودين كذلك دار انوه انه
ما بس القصف واطلاق الرشاد كمان في
مفقودين في في الخرطوم حتى لما يطلع شخص
من منزله ويذهب الى
بكثير من صور المفقودين هذا من ضمن الفوضى
التي حدثت في ظل هذه الاشتباكات ام ان
تتوقعين ان هناك من طرفي النزاع من له باع
في هذا حسب الشواهد بالامس كنت اتحدث مع
احد اللجان المقاومه
تصريحاتهم انه يتم ايقاف المواطنين من قبل
الدعم السريع في الشارع في من القوات من
الدعم السريع انتهت حرمه البيوت في بيوت
اخذوا منها طعام اخذوا منها مبالغ ماليه
سرقات كذلك في السيارات حتى الذاهبين مصر
كانوا في كم شخص بيحكي تجربته السيئه من
من قبل النهب من قوات الدعم السريع اداره
لان السودان ما فيه بنزين بتاع عربات ما
فيه جاز الانترنت ضعيف جدا في انقطاع جزئي
للانترنت بالامس كانت شبكه زين سوداني
انت انا الوحيده كانت شغاله اليوم زين
رجعت بتقطع ام تي ان حتى الانترنت ما
متوفر التواصل مع اهلنا في السودان صعب
للغايه الكثير فروا الى الجنوب الى مصر
الى تشاد واثيوبيا ما رايك في الروايه
التي تتحدث من انه هناك طرف ثالث وهنا
الاشاره طبعا دائما ما تكون الى فلول
النظام بانها هي من تقف وراء هذه الفوضى
اعتقد انه دي روايه ساذجه لانه اذا شفنا
الدعم السريع اول جيش هم الاثنين من خلفهم
المنظومه الحاكم السابقه اليوم احنا عندنا
دعم سريع وجيش يتنازعون والاثنين هم
مسؤولين مسؤوليه كامله عن انتهاك وقتل
المواطنين السودانيين من باب اولى التوجيه
للمسؤولين من الحرب اللي هم البرهان
وحميتي مسؤوليه مباشره انه يتحملوا وزره
الشعب السوداني اللي شرد في ظل ماساه
قاموا بها هؤلاء شخصين مع بعضهم البعض
من لندن دكتوره رؤى عربي الصحفيه
والاعلاميه السودانيه شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
بعد اخر للازمه في السودان مراقبون يرون
ان ما يحدث ليبقى داخل السودان فحسب حاله
تفاقم النزاع فقد تمتد حرب اهليه تلوح في
الافق الى سبع دول يتشارك السودان حدودا
ملتهبه معها بالاستناد الى عاملين مدى
استمراريه النزاع ونتيجه هذا النساء نتابع
حقائب موظبه وصرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل انه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيين على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل
بشان سد النهضه التهديد المائي ليس فقط ما
تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها الكهرومائيه
فالمناوشات على الحدود غير منقطعه اصلا
وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده التوتر بمنطقه
الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمد تي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور النشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه الفا من مواطنيها قد يضطرون
لحزم امتعتهم من جديد
هذا ودخل حوالي عشره الاف لاجئ سوداني الى
الاراضي الواقعه في جنوب السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه هربا من القتال الدائر
فيما عبر الحدود حوالي
6500 لاجئ سوداني يوم السبت الماضي في وقت
لا تزال اعداد اللاجئين مرشحه للزياده مع
استمرار المواجهات
وهناك ازمه اخرى تلوح في الافق ازمه صحيه
وفي سبيل ذلك طالبت منظمه الصحه العالميه
بعدم استهداف المرافق الصحيه والعاملين
والمرضى بعدما وثقت عده هجمات مميته
استهدفت المؤسسات الصحيه نتابعه
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السوداني اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
المتقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتلى ب 132 ثلاث
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا في
عدد المرشح للزياده المعوقات اللي نحن
بنواجهك هلال احمد سوداني تواجهها كل
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله في السودان
اللي هي ابرزه عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه من جانبها اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء ان 72% من المستشفيات القريبه من
مناطق الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل 79
مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه والولايات من
المجموع الكلي للمستشفيات بقي اثنتان
وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او جزئي
لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر فيها
الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الوصول
اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان اربعه
مستشفيات في مدينه الاوبيض تعرضت للقصف ما
يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات التي قصفت
الى 13 مستشفى
اليها تسعه عشر مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري كما تعرضت ست مركبات اسعاف
للاعتداء من قبل قوات عسكريه بينما لم يتم
السماح لعدد من سيارات الاسعاف بالمرور
لنقل المرضى وايصال المعونات حسب ما قالت
نقابه اطباء السودان من جانبه طالب الهلال
الاحمر بتحييد المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات
القتاليه لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع
الصحي في السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
اذا اسبوع ثاني من المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان لا صوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص ولا
مؤشر ينذر بحل قريب المواجهه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بدات باطلاق نار كثيف حول
مباني المدينه الرياضيه في منطقه سوبا
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم القتال من بعدها
انتقل سريعا الى حي المطار وهو متاخم لمقر
القياده العامه للجيش حيث يوجد بيت
الضيافه والذي يقيم فيه طرف الحرب البرهان
ودقل وكبار القاده العسكريين وسط الخرطوم
وبينما تداولت وسائل الاعلام عن الدعم
السريع سيطرته على مطار مروي والقاعده
الجويه اضافه الى الاعلان عن احتجاز عدد
من الضباط كانوا في القاعده تم تداول
معلومات عن استيلاء قوات الدعم السريعه
على القصر الجمهوري في قلب الخرطوم اضافه
الى اجزاء واسعه من مقر القياده العامه
للجيش نيران الحريق امتدت بعدها الى خارج
الخرطوم لتصل عددا من المدن كان يالا
والفاشر والجنيه في ولايات دارفور ومدينه
الابيض في ولايه شمال كردفان القتال تركز
ايضا حول مقرات الدعم السريع في شارع بيت
ختم وفي مدينه بحري وام درمان ليس معروفا
على وجه الدقه ما يسيطر على ماذا فكل طرف
يزعم بسط سيطرته على موقع استراتيجي قبل
ان يبادر الاخر سريعا باعلان الشيء نفسه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وردتنا الان
للاستهداف الذي ذكرناه في بدايه هذه
النشره لمنطقه الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم اذا
هذه المنطقه والمنازل السكنيه تعرضت
لاستهداف يقال بانه للطائرات بحسب توثيق
وتداول لبعض الصور على وسائل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هذه الصور
الحصريه للعربيه للمنازل المستهدفه طبعا
الجانب الطبي تحدث عن سقوط سبعه مدنيين
قتلى في هذا القصف عدد الجرحى بالعشرات
ولكن لم يتم لم يتم تحديد العدد بالكامل
اذا صور حصريه للعربيه تظهر منطقه
الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم بعد تعرضها وتعرض
منازل المدنيين فيها لقصف جوي
الى موجز لاهم الانباء في دول العالم
صراحه الخارجيه الصينيه انها تحترم سياده
الدول الاعضاء سابقا في الاتحاد السوفيتي
وذلك بعد ان كان مبعوث الصين الى فرنسا قد
شكك في تصريحات له بسياده تلك الدول
كاوكرانيا
بعد تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي كانت الصين من
اوائل الدول التي اقامت علاقات دبلوماسيه
مع جمهوريه السوفياتيه السابقه ومنذ اقامه
تلك العلاقات التزمت الصين دائما بمبادئ
الاحترام المتبادل والمعامله المتساويه
لتطوير العلاقات الوديه والتعاونيه
الثنائيه ويحترم الجانب الصيني مكانتها
كدول ذات السياده بعد تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي
اعلنت بريطانيا فرض مزيد من العقوبات على
مسؤولين ايرانيين من بينهم عناصر من الحرس
الثوري وذلك بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي الحكومه البريطانيه
اوضحت ان العقوبات شملت اربعه من قاده
الحرس الثوري التي قالت انهم قاموا
بانتهاكات ضد حقوق الانسان
كشف وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار ان
اجتماعا رباعيا يضم تركيا وسوريا وروسيا
وايضا ايران سيعقد غدا في العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو يذكر ان عمليه تطبيع العلاقات بين
انقره ودمشق كانت قد انطلقت في نهايه
ديسمبر العام الماضي في موسكو عندما جرت
مشاورات بين وزراء دفاع روسيا وسوريا
وتركيا وتم خلال الاجتماع الاتفاق على
تشكيل لجنه ثلاثيه مشتركه نتابعه
كما تعلمون عقد اجتماع في موسكو في 28 من
ديسمبر الماضي حضره وزراء الدفاع ورؤساء
المخابرات من تركيا وروسيا وسوريا
وتبادلنا وجهات النظر واتفقنا على حل بعض
المشاكل واستئناف هذه اللقاءات في
المستقبل كما ناقشنا مشاركه ايران في هذه
الاجتماعات وتم الاتفاق على ذلك لاحقا
واستمرارا لذلك نستعد لاجتماع سيعقد في
موسكو في 25 من ابريل بحضور وزراء دفاع
ورؤساء مخابرات الدول الاربع
وبهذا مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الساعه ولكن التغطيه مستمره على راس
الساعه فاطمه والمزيد مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات